>>> WE HAVE BREAKINGEWS NOW IN
THE IO REPUBLICAN SENATE
PRIMARY RACE
CNN CAN NOW PROJECT THAT JD
VANCE WILL WIN THE GOP
NOMINATION.
LET'S GO RIGHT TO JOHN KING AT
THE MAGIC WALL.
JOHN, WHAT ARE YOU TELLING US?
>> THIS IS VICTORY FOR JD VANCE
AND ALSO A VICTORY -- YOU CANNOT
SUGAR COAT THIS -- FOR TRUMP AS
WELL.
WE HAVE ABOUT 70% OF THE VOTE
COUNTED NOW.
THIS LEAD HAS STRETCHED OVER THE
LAST HOUR.
JD VANCE WITH 31% OF THE VOTE,
JOSH MAN DEL A VERY PRO-TRUMP
CANDIDATE BUT DID NOT GET
TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT.
MAT DOLAND WAS IN THE HUNT EARLY
ON BUT HE SIMPLY FADED.
SEE ALL THESE RURAL COLORS HERE,
JUST LIKE TRUMP BUILT IT UP IN
OHIO AND RAN AWAY WITH THE STATE
AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
RURAL OHIO NOT EXCLUSIVELY BUT
VERY MUCH POWERING THE MAP
BEHIND WHAT WILL BE A JD VANCE
VICTORY.
AGAIN, RELATIVELY CLOSE IN SOME
OF THEM, BUT YOU PICK UP SEVERAL
HUNDRED VOTES IN A SMALL RURAL
COUNTY LIKE THAT, YOU MOVE OVER
HERE YOU'RE PICKING UP SEVERAL
HUNDRED MORE VOTES HERE.
THIS IS HOW DONALD TRUMP DOES IT
IN SMALL TOWN AMERICA WITH JD
VANCE DOING IT IN OHIO TONIGHT.
IN A PLACE WHERE IF MATT DOLAND
WAS TO HAVE AN UPSET HE NEEDED
TO DO IT DOWN HERE, THE THIRD
LARGEST COUNTY IN THE STATE,
HAMILTON COUNTY THAT IS
CINCINNATI.
RUNNING NAR LOW AHEAD RIGHT NOW,
BUT IF THERE WAS TO BE AN
ESTABLISHMENT STRIKE MOMENT FOR
DONALD TRUMP THIS WOULD BE AT
THE MOMENT 26% WITH JD VANCE
LEADING THERE.
JUST LOOK THIS IS HOW IF YOU GO
BACK TO THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE IN
2020 SEE ALL THAT RED, THAT'S
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S HOW HE DOES IT.
JOE BIDEN WON IN CLEVELAND, WON
IN CINCINNATI, COLUMBUS.
JOE BIDEN WON THE THREE LARGEST
COUNTIES IN OHIO BUT WON ONLY
SEVEN BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP RUNS
IT UP, JD VANCE HE'S AT 31%
BECAUSE OF THE CROWDED FIELD,
BUT WE PROJECT IN THE WINNER
BECAUSE OF THAT, AND THERE'S NO
DOUBT -- NO DOUBT ON THIS ONE
NIGHT IF THIS PLAYS OUT IN THE
PRIMARY SEASON A VICTORY FOR
VANCE IS A VICTORY FOR TRUMP.
>> LET'S BRING IN OUR TOP
POLITICAL BINDS, ABBEY PHILIP,
DAVID CHALIAN AND DANA BASH.
I'M WONDERING WHO'S RELIEVED AND
WHO'S ANXIOUS NOW.
ABBEY, PREDICTED OR NOT SPH.
>> YEAH, I THINK EXPECTED GIVEN
THE TRUMP ENDORSEMENT FOR SURE.
YOU KNOW, OF ALL THE CANDIDATES
IN THE TRUMPY WING OF THE PARTY
I THINK VANCE IS ONE THAT THE
ESTABLISHMENT THINKS THEY CAN
LIVE WITH.
YOU KNOW, HE MADE A SHARP TURN
TOWARDS TRUMP IN ORDER TO RUN
THIS RACE, BUT I THINK BY AND
LARGE MANY REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT-TYPES FROM WHAT I
HAVE HEARD, THEY FEEL LIKE HE
CAN RUN A GENERAL ELECTION
EFFECTIVELY IN THAT STATE AND
PERFORM -- PERFORM YOU KNOW
DECENTLY.
AND ESPECIALLY IF YOU LOOK AT
SOME OF THESE PRIMARY, YOU KNOW,
RETURNS AS THEY'RE COMING IN,
HE'S DOING WELL IN THE KIND OF
MORE RURAL AREAS, BUT HE'S ALSO
DOING OKAY IN SUBURBAN AREAS.
AND I THINK THOSE ARE TWO KIND
OF FACTORS THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO LOOK AT TO SEE HOW HE
MIGHT PERFORM IN A GENERAL
ELECTION AND NOT TO MENTION THE
FACT OHIO HAS JUST BECOME A MUCH
MORE CONSERVATIVE STATE, AND SO
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN UPHILL
BATTLE FOR DEMOCRATS.
IT ALMOST DOESN'T MATTER WHO THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE ENDS UP
BEING.
>> DANA, I HEAR YOU
ACKNOWLEDGING AS WELL AND
ECHOING THAT SENTIMENT OF HOW
THIS MAY BE ABLE TO BE
EXTRAPOLATED BEYOND OHIO.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL YOU ABOUT
THE ABILITY OF DONALD TRUMP TO
ENDORSE A CANDIDATE TO A
SUCCESSFUL PRIMARY VICTORY BUT
ALSO WHAT IT MIGHT SPEAK TO
OTHER STATE PRIMARIES THAT ARE
COMING UP?
IS IT A LITMUS TEST?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY NATIONALLY CLEARLY IS AT
THE BASE OF IT, THE PRIMARY
VOTERS CLEARLY DO STILL SUPPORT
DONALD TRUMP AND TRUMPISM.
EACH STATE IS DIFFERENT.
YOU JUST SHOWED THAT OHIO IN
PARTICULAR OR JOHN DID, OHIO IN
PARTICULAR HAS BECOME MUCH MORE
RED IN EVERY WAY.
PENNSYLVANIA IS A STATE THAT IS
COMING UP WHEN THIS OTHER
PRIMARY TEST WILL BE OUT THERE,
WHETHER OR NOT A TRUMP ENDORSED
CANDIDATE, DR. OZ, WILL BEAT
SOMEBODY -- OR THERE'S A FEW
CANDIDATES BUT SOMEBODY WHO'S
MORE REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT IN
DAVE McCORMICK.
IT'S UNCLEAR GIVEN THAT
ELECTORATE YOU'LL SEE THE SAME
KIND OF DYNAMIC YOU SAW TONIGHT
IN OHIO.
WHAT IS ALSO UNCLEAR, AGAIN,
WHAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER IS HOW A TRUMP ENDORSED
CANDIDATE IS GOING TO DO UP
AGAINST WHOMEVER THE DEMOCRAT IS
GOING TO BE.
IT'S ALSO ALL AND ESPECIALLY NOW
STARTING IN OHIO IT IS ABOUT THE
GENERAL ELECTIONS.
ALL THE QUESTIONS YOU WERE
ASKING BEFORE, HOW THE SUPREME
COURT POTENTIAL DECISION ON
ABORTION COMES INTO PLAY, OTHER
FACTORS COMES INTO PLAY, THAT
WILL ALL DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
THIS OHIO SEAT WHICH ROB
PORTMAN, THE REPUBLICAN IS
LEAVING, STAYS IN GOP HANDS.
>> I WANT TO BRING YOU IN ON
THAT VERY NOTION BECAUSE I'M
CURIOUS ESPECIALLY WHAT ABBEY
WAS SPEAKING ABOUT IN PARTICULAR
THE IDEA OF AND WHAT JOHN WAS
EXPLAINING WHERE THESE VOTES
WERE COMING FROM, HOW TO LOOK AT
THIS IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
COMPOSITION OF THESE VOTERS WHO
WERE GALVANIZED TO COME OUT AND
VOTE ACTUALLY MEANS.
>> YEAH, THIS IS CERTAINLY AS
JOHN POINTED OUT A TRUMP COUNTRY
KIND OF TURN OUT FOR JD VANCE.
REMEMBER WE'RE SAYING THAT IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY, RIGHT?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE GENERAL
ELECTION MAP YOU SEE HOW
DEMOCRATS HAVE LOST ANY FOOTHOLD
EVEN IN PLACES LIKE OHIO WHERE
THEY USED TO HAVE IT IN TERMS OF
RURAL AREAS, AND DONALD TRUMP
SORT OF WIPED THAT AWAY IN HIS
LAST TWO PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS.
BUT WHAT'S INTERESTING TO SEE IS
NOW THAT WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO
BE JD VANCE VERSUS TIM RYAN,
IT'S LIKE HOW DOES THAT SHAPE UP
AND MINUTES OF VANCE BEING
PROJECTED THE WINNER HERE TRYING
TO FRAME HIM AS A CALIFORNIA
ELITIST WHO MADE A LOT OF MONEY
FROM A NETFLIX MOVIE ON IT AND
NOT OF OHIO.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE A TRUMP
ENDORSED CANDIDATE WHO JUST
PULLED A LOT OF VOTES FROM RURAL
OHIO THAT THAT KIND OF FRAME
WILL STICK.
>> I WANT TO GO TO JEFF ZELENY.
LIVE AT VANCE HEADQUARTERS IN
CINCINNATI.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING OVER THERE,
JEFF?
>> Reporter: WE'RE SEEING A LOT
OF EXCITED SUPPORTERS.
YOU CAN SEE THE CROWD BEHIND ME
LISTENING TO THE SONG "GLORIA."
AND THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
ENDORSEMENT FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
ABOUT 2 1/2 WEEKS AGO LED TO
THIS VICTORY TONIGHT.
THE QUESTION GOING FORWARD IS
CAN HE CONSOLIDATE OTHER
REPUBLICANS?
AND JUST TALKING TO A VARIETY OF
REPUBLICANS WHO SUPPORTED HIS
CHALLENGER, THEY SAY, YES.
THEY SAY JD VANCE CAN SPEAK TO
THE BASE OF THE PARTY, WHICH HE
PROVED TONIGHT, AND HE CAN ALSO
SPEAK TO THE INTELLIGENT OF THE
PARTY.
SO THIS IS QUITE EXTRAORDINARY.
JUST ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO HE
WAS NEAR THE BOTTOM OF THE PACK,
AND IT WAS THAT ENDORSEMENT AT A
RALLY IN DELAWARE COUNTY FROM
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP THEY DID
INDEED GIVE HIM THE CREDIBILITY
TO OVERCOME ALL THE DOUBTERS.
BUT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
TONIGHT UNTIL IS JD VANCE TRYING
TO UNIFY THIS REPUBLICAN PARTY?
AND IMMEDIATELY GOING AFTER TIM
RYAN HE WILL BE TRYING TO
PORTRAY HIM AS SIMPLY PART OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, PART OF
THE BIDEN PARTY -- HE MAY SAY
TONIGHT.
SO CLEARLY THIS IS A LARGE WIN
FOR JD VANCE IN HIS FIRST BID
FOR HIS OFFICE, AND THIS IS
GOING TO BE A TEST.
BUT WE DO KNOW OHIO IS
INCREASINGLY BECOMING A RED
STATE.
SO WILL THIS BE COMPETITIVE